a huge part of maintaining security in
the cloud is enforcing the age-old
principle of least privilege
users and service accounts should only
have the minimum permissions needed to
perform what they actually need to do
if you're involved with identity and
access management or iim how can you be
sure that excess permissions aren't
granted
and as your workload evolves over time
how do you know if the initial set of
permissions assigned are appropriate or
if you need to make some changes that's
where activeassist policy intelligence
and iam recommender can help
users and applications access the
resources in your google cloud projects
by authenticating as users or service
accounts we refer to these accounts as
principles the level of access of each
principle is determined by the
permissions specified in the iim policy
these permissions are grouped into
distinct iam roles to make it easy to
assign access based on different needs
for example the compute network admin
role is a built-in role that grants full
control of compute engine networking
resources this role includes more than
400 permissions such as all the
permissions to create and manage
subnetworks
the compute network user role another
built-in role for using but not managing
compute engine networking resources has
less than 100 permissions
any principle with this role can list
and use existing subnetworks but not
create modify or delete them
meanwhile the compute network viewer
role grants over 100 permissions
including the permission for listing
health checks
each of these roles provides different
levels of access to the same set of
resources
as you can imagine managing many
principles and roles for a collection of
resources can become pretty complex
pretty quickly and might result in too
much or too little access
does the first user actually need the
compute network admin role and is the
compute network user role enough access
for the second user
could a malicious actor take advantage
of over granted permissions to cause
damage
thankfully the recommendations from
activeassist policy intelligence can
help us answer questions like these
policy intelligence is a suite of tools
under the active assist intelligent
tools category these policy intelligence
tools are designed to help you make
informed decisions about the iam
policies on your project and perform
audits and compliance related tasks
policy analyzer helps you understand who
has access to which google cloud
resources policy simulator shows you how
a change to an iam policy might impact
the principal's existing access before
the change is actually made
policy troubleshooter examines all iam
policies that apply to a resource to
show you why a principal might not have
access and the best way to fix it
and finally there's the iam recommender
which offers you two primary benefits
first it identifies the principles that
might have excess permissions granted to
them the recommender spots those excess
permissions and uses machine learning to
predict future usage this information is
saved as policy insights for you to
understand your policy usage at the
project folder or organization level
the excess permissions are identified by
comparing the permissions that each
principal has used in the past 90 days
with the total permissions that that
principal has
second the iim recommender assesses each
role granted to a principal to determine
if there's a better fit while optimizing
for least privilege
these suggestions could be for a more
appropriate role multiple roles or
remove all the permissions together
suggested roles might include built-in
roles like the ones that we've mentioned
earlier or custom roles
custom roles can include any combination
of permissions so there's a lot of ways
that you can control the roles and
permissions that your principles have
let's take a look at what the im
recommender looks like from the cloud
console for this demonstration i have
the iam recommender admin role to view
and manage the im recommendations
and the project iim admin role so that i
can update the project iam policy with
those recommendations
lets take a look at the iam and admin
page where the iim policies for our
project folder and organizations are
managed
this view is for our project where we've
got some recommendations available
at the top we'll find a banner with some
priority recommendations
we can click here to add a filter to our
table below
the light bulb icon in the security
insights column means that our ml models
have identified a recommendation for
that principle
for example this particular service
account has the editor role assigned to
it which is a role with a lot of
permissions as you can see here
the recommendation here is to replace
the editor role with the storage object
admin role for this principle
on the right are the individual
permissions that will be removed if
making the recommended change
we can accept the recommendation here by
clicking apply
that recommendation will now appear on
the recommendations history page
here's where we can see how many
recommendations have been applied and
what the details are
when we select the recommendation
there's a summary of the change
including the list of the permissions
that we saw before
if anything were to come up and we would
need to undo the change we can click
revert to restore the permissions
for another view of our iim
recommendations we can head over to the
recommendations hub
since we only have the iim
recommendation admin role assigned those
are the only kinds of recommendations
that will show up on this screen
clicking view all shows us all the
recommendations matching this category
and selecting one of those
recommendations will give us additional
details
just as before we can review the changes
the recommendation suggests including
the permission for the current role and
the permissions for the recommended
replacement role
if our iim policies are managed with the
infrastructure as code solution
terraform we would click use terraform
to see the proposed change as a code
snippet in terraform configuration
otherwise we can just click apply to
update the project iim policy with the
role change
the iam recommender helps you improve
your security posture on google cloud
focusing on the principle of least
privilege with a set of machine learning
learning-powered analyses
we saw what these recommendations look
like from the google cloud console but
you can also access and manage them
through the api and google cloud command
line interface
you can find links in the description
for more information on policy
intelligence and using the iam
recommender as part of the active assist
portfolio
don't forget about the recommendation
hub where you can see all sorts of
helpful recommendations
stay tuned for the next video where
we'll look at some ways that you can
take these recommendations and apply
them at scale see you there